Okay, schönen guten Tag.
Schönen guten Tag.
Ich bin der zuständige Arzt für Sie.
Bevor wir anfangen, lasst uns bitte Ihre Daten notieren.
Danach bespicken wir Ihre Beschwerde.
Okay?
Ja, also ich bin mit meiner Mutter hier.
Und ihr geht es überhaupt nicht gut.
Aber Sie wollte selber nicht zum Arzt gehen.
Und ja, warum nicht?
Sie hört sehr schlecht.
Und dann hat sie immer das Gefühl, dass sie nicht verstanden wird.
Und darum bin ich jetzt mitgekommen.
Und kann Ihnen ein bisschen etwas über meine Mutter erzählen.
Und ich mache mir wirklich große Sorgen in Sie.
Okay, das ist sehr gut, dass Sie dabei sind.
Und erst mal, wie heißt Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter heißt Gerda Mais.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Mutter das Name Buchstabieren?
Ja, der Vorname ist G-E-R-D-A.
Und der Familienname ist Mais, M-A-I-S.
Okay, Frau Mais.
Und Ihre Name ist Aufgau-Mais, ja?
Nein, ich bin verheiratet.
Und meine Mutter heißt Thomas mit Nachnamen.
Okay, Frau Thomas.
Wie heißt Ihre Mutter?
Ja, sie ist, ich habe das auch beschrieben.
76 Jahre ist sie alt, ja, genau.
Und wann genau ist sie Februar?
Am 12. Februar 1946.
Okay. Wie groß ist sie?
Ach ja, ich meine, sie war immer so 168.
Ja, ich meine, da steht so ein Paar drin, ja.
Okay, und wie viel wiegt sie?
Also, ich war letztens mit ihr beim Hausarzt und da hat sie 72 kg gerogen.
71 kg.
Okay, ist Frau Mais verheiratet?
Ja, sie ist verheiratet, mein Vater lebt noch.
Aber ist natürlich auch schon älter und der wollte jetzt nicht mitkommen heute.
Okay, Frau Thomas, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe noch eine Schwester.
Okay, Sie sind zwei.
Und was war Ihr Büro?
Was war Ihr Mutter?
Ja, meine Mutter.
Der Beruf meiner Mutter?
Ja, bis zur Rente hat sie im Finanzamt gearbeitet als Angestellte.
Obwohl, da hat ihr das dann mit den Hörproblemen schon ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten gemacht.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Okay, und was für Beischwerte hat sie?
Ja, also, gucken Sie, meine Mutter ist wirklich ganz elend.
Sie hören ja, dass sie hustet, ganz schrecklich.
Sie hat auch Fieber.
Und sie sagt jetzt auch, dass der Husten ihr wehtut.
Und das macht mir so ein bisschen Sorgen.
Das war jetzt schon seit vier Tagen.
Und ich habe das Gefühl, das wird irgendwie immer schlimmer.
Und nachts, also wir wohnen in der Nachbarwohnung.
Und ich höre sie durch die Wände,
und ich habe diese schreckliche Husten.
Und ich habe auch das Gefühl, sie schläft überhaupt gar nicht gut.
Und nach dem Essen ist es auch ganz schlimm.
Da hustet sie, also denkt man, sie hat irgendwie sich verschluckt.
Aber eigentlich ist sie vorsichtig.
Aber sie ist wirklich ganz eingeschränkt im Augenblick.
Und wir haben ihr natürlich ein bisschen Hustensaft gegeben.
Und auch so ein Hustenlöser.
Aber das hat alles überhaupt nichts gebracht.
Und ich habe jetzt so das Gefühl, es geht ihr mit jedem Tag ein bisschen schlechter.
Und ja, das habe ich gedacht, muss ich doch wirklich mal mit ihr hier zu Ihnen kommen.
Okay, wir haben gut gemacht.
Und Sie haben schon gesagt, seit vier Tagen
haben Sie die Husten schlimmer geworden.
Also seit wann hat sie diese Beschwerden?
Ja, also seit vier Tagen hustet sie überhaupt.
Aber jetzt ist es eben seit gestern, würde ich sagen,
eben so schlimm geworden, dass sie so schlapp ist.
Und dass sie auch so hohes Fieber hat.
Haben Sie die Fieber gemessen von Ihrer Mutter?
Ja, ich muss mal, eine Sekunde, irgendwo habe ich das Fieber.
Sekunde, ich soll nicht.
Ja, Fieber über 40, genau.
Also gestern Abend hatte sie über 40 Fieber.
Und da habe ich schon ein bisschen schreckt bekommen.
Und ich meine, ich bin da noch mal drüben gewesen bei ihr,
weil ich mir so Sorgen gemacht habe.
Also, da war sie auch ganz verschwitzt.
Ich habe ihr da noch mal ein neues Nachtjammt angezogen.
Und also sie saß da wirklich im Bett und hat geröchelt.
Also das war ein bisschen beängstigend.
Hat sie die kinderische Medikamente gegen Fieber eingenommen?
Gegen das Fieber habe ich ihr jetzt nichts gegeben,
nur gegen den Husten.
Okay.
Außer Husten und Fieber, hat sie Atelnot?
Ja, also schon, sie zieht schon wirklich so nach Luft.
Man hat das Gefühl, dass sie sich quält beim Husten.
Wissen Sie, ob sie unter Brustschmerzen leidet?
Hat sie jetzt nicht so richtig gesagt, aber sie fasst sich da so hin.
Insofern denke ich schon, dass ihr das weh tut.
Wo genau tut weh?
Ja, dass sie so beim Husten sich so mit das Haust auf das Brustbein sozusagen.
Als ob sie da irgendwie so einen Gegendruck ausüben soll.
Okay.
Und Sie haben auch gesagt, nach dem Wissen besonders ist die Husten schlimmer.
Hat sie Schluppe schwerer beim Essen?
Nein, das eigentlich nicht.
Normalerweise kommt sie völlig klar beim Essen.
Aber jetzt habe ich das Gefühl, dass sie da besonders doll hustet.
Was meinen Sie nach dem Essen?
Nein, so unmittelbar nach dem Essen.
Okay.
Nun ist sie in der letzte Zeit gereist?
Nein, zurzeit kann man ja eigentlich nicht gut verreisen.
Und die beiden sind sehr feustlich.
Ist sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja klar, gegen Corona ist sie auch geimpft.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass die geschwollene Beine hat?
Nein, das kenne ich eigentlich nicht von ihr.
Nein.
Okay.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen zu Ihren Abwellebeschwerter?
Nein, ich habe ziemlich viel beschrieben dazu.
Ich denke mal, das andere müssen Sie dann untersuchen,
was Sie rausfinden können.
Ja, natürlich mache ich nach der Umfalt.
Was vielleicht noch wichtig ist,
dass Sie tatsächlich bei dem Husten auch ordentlich Schleim produziert.
Ach so, ja.
Okay, Schleim.
Ich habe ein gutes Zeug, das sieht nicht gut aus.
Könnten Sie mir sagen, wie ist die Fahrnünfte und Ausbruch?
Ja, es hat sich gerade gelb.
Gelblich.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Ihnen Ausbruch blutgibt?
Nein, das habe ich nicht gesehen.
Okay.
Also, leitet Sie an chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, in der Alter, wissen Sie, da hat man schon ein bisschen...
Er hat schon ewig lange einen Zucker, schon seit 30 Jahren.
Und natürlich hat sie auch ein bisschen Bluthochdruck.
Also, warum?
Weil es wegen des Zuckers war sie auch in den letzten paar Monaten.
War sie zweimal im Krankenhaus, weil das ein bisschen entgleist war.
Aber eigentlich war sie jetzt wieder stabil die letzten Wochen.
Geht es Sie regelmäßig zum Eindruck, in der Login?
Ja, klar.
Okay.
Und die Zucker ist unter Kontrolle?
Eingestellt?
Ja, normalerweise.
Was da jetzt war, dass sie da vor im letzten halben Jahr zweimal in die Klinik musste.
Vielleicht hat sie ein bisschen gesündigt,
oder was weiß ich, ihre Tabletten vergessen.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Aber jedenfalls ging es ihr, deine Weile mal nicht so gut.
Und dann musste sie eben ins Krankenhaus, aber danach war es wieder okay.
Okay, um seit wann leidet sie Bluthochdruck?
Ja, das hat sie schon, ah, bestimmt 25 Jahre.
Also, Sie haben auch gesagt, Sie haben ein Verbrech Probleme.
Ja.
Wissen Sie, welche Diagnose wurde bei dir festgestellt?
Nein, ich weiß nur, dass sie irgendwann das gemerkt hat,
dass sie nicht gut hört und dass sie dann mit einem Hörgerät versorgt worden ist.
Aber damit kann sie sich nicht so gut anfreunden.
Und ja, deswegen.
Vielleicht, das wäre eine Hörgerechtheit, ja?
Ja, denke ich mal, ja.
Okay.
Ist sie schon mal operiert worden?
Nee, so viel, ich weiß nicht. Nein.
Okay.
Und gibt es in Ihrer Familie wesentliche Erklankungen,
von denen Sie wissen sollten, also bei Ihrer Großeltern?
Bei meinen Großeltern, jetzt muss ich richtig zurück überlegen.
Ja.
Also, ich weiß, dass der Großvater auch immer den Blutdruck messen musste.
Der hatte, glaube ich, auch ein bisschen erhöhten Blutdruck,
aber der ist eigentlich auch ziemlich alt geworden.
Und Ihre Mutter ist tatsächlich an Brustkrebs gestorben.
Und sind Sie gesund?
Oder Ihre Geschwester auch?
Ja, wir sind beide gesund. Ja, meine Schwester und ich wissen gesund.
Okay, geht Sie regelmäßig zum Frauenarzt?
Regelmäßig würde ich jetzt vielleicht nichts sagen.
Man muss hier so ein bisschen,
wie ich jetzt eben Sie auch hierher begleitet habe.
Ich muss Sie so ein bisschen schubsen, dass Sie geht, aber...
Also alle paar Jahre kriege ich Sie auch zum Gelobeln.
Nehmen Sie sich, wann war die letzte Kontrolle?
War die letzte Kontrolle, ne? Genau.
Das ist bestimmt zwei Jahre her.
Aber da war eigentlich alles in Ordnung.
Okay.
Schleft Frau Meifroth?
Normalerweise schläft sie eigentlich ganz gut.
Aber jetzt, diese Nächte hat sie gar nicht gut geschlafen.
Okay, wegen Küsten, ja.
Ja, ja, genau.
Okay, und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Also zurzeit schmeckt ihr überhaupt nicht.
Normalerweise ist sie eigentlich ganz gut.
Und ja, das ist auch wichtig, weil sie beiden in Gesellschaft sind.
Also Vater und Mutter sitzen zusammen und dann schmeckt es ihr wohl ganz gut.
Aber jetzt in diesen Tagen schmeckt es ihr nicht.
Da ist sie gar nicht gut.
Hat sie in der letzten Zeit Gewicht verloren?
Ja, das kann sein.
Ich kann das nicht so genau verfolgen, weil ich sie natürlich nicht morgens
jeden Tag auf die Ware stelle, ne?
Ja, ja.
Aber kann schon sein, dass sie ein bisschen abgenommen hat,
weil sie die letzten Tage wirklich nicht viel gegessen hat.
Also passt Ihre Kleidung noch?
Ja, sie passt schon noch.
Also zugenommen hat sie sicherlich nicht.
Vielleicht hat sie ein bisschen abgenommen, kann sagen.
Und hat Frau Meis Probleme bei einem Stuhlgang oder was er das nicht?
Ja, also hin und wieder mal so ein bisschen Probleme mit Inkontinent,
was Frauen in ihrem Alter halt so haben, aber eigentlich unauffällig,
würde ich sagen.
Also gibt es etwas, was Frau Meis mental belastet oder siebisch belastet?
Ja, vielleicht leidet sie unter ihrer Schwerhörigkeit.
Das kann natürlich gut sein.
Aber eigentlich mit meinem Vater ist sie gut eingespielt,
die kommen gut zurecht.
Und ich glaube, die kann eigentlich ganz zufrieden sein.
Und ich glaube, ich bin froh, dass sie nicht mehr arbeiten muss,
dass das alles ein bisschen ruhiger geht.
Gut.
Also sie hat Zuckerkrankheit, eine Mühluftuchtlug.
Nimmst du dagegen, regnest du mit Kamel zu einem?
Ja, klar, natürlich.
Also sie nimmt mit Formin ein.
Wie viel Milligramm?
Ich meine 1000 nimmt sie ein, eine morgens und eine abends.
Okay.
Und was noch?
Dann nimmt sie HCT 12,5, eine morgens.
Und Ramipril nimmt sie auch noch, 10 Milligramm morgens und abends.
Dann nimmt sie bei Bedarf mit Kamel rein.
Sie haben schon gesagt, die Husten darf und Hustenlöser.
Ja, also den Husten, das ist so etwas,
was ich aus dem Drogeriemarkt gekauft habe.
Und das HCT, das gebe ich nämlich selber immer,
wenn ich Husten habe, da habe ich ihr mal jetzt so Brausetabletten
aufgelöst.
Aber das hat nicht so richtig viel gebracht.
Nicht noch etwas?
Ja, also wenn sie mal Kopfschmerzen hat oder so,
dann nimmt sie ruhig mal einen Aspirin,
dann ist ja alle so mal nehmen.
Wie oft nimmt sie die Aspirin?
Nicht oft.
Das ist ein, zwei Mal im Monat, glaube ich.
Okay.
Wissen Sie, ja, Sie wissen, dass ich eine Frischhaube raucht.
Nee, Sie hat nie geraucht.
Gott sei Dank, Herr.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ganz selten.
Wenn wir mal eine Familie ein Feier haben
oder wenn Besuch kommt oder so,
dann trinkt sie mal ein Glas Wein mit.
Aber normalerweise nicht.
Okay.
Und nimmt sie Drogen?
Nee, also das nun wirklich nicht.
Nein.
Okay.
Ist bei ihr allergiebekannt?
Nein, also kann ich mich nicht erinnern,
dass da irgendwas jemals war.
Wir haben in der Familie alle keine Allergien.
Nee, also bei ihr ist nichts, nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Oder hat sie irgendwelche Lebens- und Verträgigkeiten?
Lebensmittel?
Nein, sie kann alles essen.
Eigentlich kann sie alles essen.
Sie mag vielleicht nicht alles, aber sie kann alles essen, ja.
Also, ihr habt noch eine Frage,
wie wir abgefügt die Schwerte stimmen.
Was sind die Herzprobleme, wie Herzraten
oder Herzklopfen?
Hat sie jetzt nicht gesagt,
würde ich nicht ausschließen,
weil sie sich so an die Brust fassen,
ob sie da mehr wegen Schmerzen mehr
oder ob sie das Gefühl hat,
dass ihr das Herz wehtut, weiß ich nicht.
Das müssten sie vielleicht bei der Untersuchung rausfinden, genauer.
Okay.
Hat sie schon mal deutsche Beschwerden gehabt
oder ist das erste Mal aufgetreten?
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass sie schon mal so elend war.
Nein.
Klar, hatte mal eine Erkältung gehabt und mal ein paar Tage gerustet.
Deswegen haben wir das jetzt auch am Anfang gar nicht so schwer genommen.
Aber als dieser Husten so schlimm wurde
und auch eben das Fieber so hoch gegangen ist
und sich ihr Allgemeinzustand so verschlechtert hat,
da haben wir gesagt, jetzt müssen wir doch mal mit ihr ins Krankenhaus gehen.
Okay.
Also, Frau Thomas, habe ich meinerseits die wichtigste Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie da zu etwas erkennen
oder an die Fragen?
Ich habe Ihnen ja so viel erzählt, ich glaube,
jetzt wüsste ich natürlich nur gerne, was Sie mit ihr machen
und ob Sie im Krankenhaus bleiben mussten.
Also Frau Thomas,
die Neuzeit hat sehr hoch Fieber,
deswegen müssen wir unbedingt die Fieber senken.
Deswegen geben wir sofort ein paar Medikamente.
Aber ich möchte erst mal die körperliche,
Frau Maes erst mal körperlich untersuchen.
Danach, wir brauchen noch ein paar weitere Untersuchungen.
Also, jetzt kann ich nicht Ihnen genau sagen,
was Sie hat.
Deswegen brauchen wir eine Brutunterrufung,
natürlich nehme Ihr Blut ab
und ich schicke euch zum Wort.
Dann, ich brauche auch eine EKG-Untraufung.
Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Und gegebenenfalls,
vielleicht je nach Befunden können wir auch
eine CT-Untersuchung durchführen.
Was für eine Untersuchung?
Also, LUM und CT.
CT, ah ja, okay.
Und danach natürlich besprechen wir,
was Sie genau hat.
Ja, okay, gut.
Alles klar.
Hat jemand Fragen?
Alle sind erschlagen.
Keiner traut sich, was Sie fragen.
Aber ich glaube, es war auch sehr, sehr vollständig.
Okay, wir brauchen noch eine Minute?
Eine Minute, ja.
Ja, alles gut.
Genau, genau, genau.
Eigentlich habe ich ja Glück gehabt,
dass das eine Fremdanase war,
sonst hätte ich zwischendurch immer so husten müssen.
Und so einen ganz leidenden Eindruck machen.
Gut, gut.
Guten Tag, Frau Oberjastin.
Wenn Sie Zeit haben,
ich möchte Ihnen eine neue Patientin vorstellen.
Oh ja, wie haben Sie den gesehen?
Also, es geht um Frau Meis.
Ihre Tochter ist dabei.
Sie hat für Sie an einem Nese gesprochen,
die Ihre Tochter durchgeführt hat.
Frau Meis hat bis zu 76 Jahre geplant.
Und 72 kg, 168 cm groß.
Also, sie klagt über seit 4 Tagen husten.
Und im Laufe der Zeit verschlechtert nicht die Hutten.
Der Hutten?
Der Hutten.
Und er hat auch Fieber.
Gestern Abend hat sie viel Temperatur.
Und die Natur wird sich gerade gemessen.
Und der Husten verschlechtert sich besonders nach dem Essen.
Und dabei gibt es auch werbische Schlein.
Und sie hat auch als weitere Beschwerden,
die sie nennen,
und das.
Und wie ist das in der Nacht?
Nacht, sie kann nicht gut schlafen.
Und warum nicht?
Weil sie wegen des Hustens.
Im Liegen muss sie so schrecklich husten.
Okay, gut.
Beim Husten hat sie auch Brust schmerzen.
Mit der Brust war es.
In der Vorerkrankung gibt es Diabetes medialtus seit 30 Jahren.
Und dagegen hat sie zweimal im Krankenhaus geblieben.
Weil entglei-singlich.
Und in welchem Zeitraum?
Ich habe das nicht gefragt, aber bei der Untersuchung frage ich.
Und sie hat auch arterielle Heteronie seit 25 Jahren.
Und sie hat auch Respy-Akuzis.
Und in der Familienanamese liegt bei der
beim Vater arteriellen Heteronie und bei der Mutter
Mama Katzenoffo.
Die geni-kologische Anamese ist immer auf.
Wegen des Hustens kann sie nicht gut schlafen.
Und ihr Appetit ist auch nicht gut seit vier Tagen.
Und sie hat auch Inkontinenz.
Sie nimmt regelmäßig mit Formin 1000 mg morgens und abends.
Und Hydrochlorothease 2,5 mg morgens.
Und Chamipril 10 mg morgens und abends.
Bei Bedarf nimmt sie Hustenlöser und Hustensat.
Aber das hat ihr nicht geholt.
Sie nimmt auch bei Bedarf 2,5 mg morgens.
Sie ist nicht saucherin und trinkt nicht viel Alkohol.
Also ein Glas Wein pro Monat.
Sie ist nicht allergisch gegen etwas.
Nach den bisherigen Angaben gehe ich von Pynomonie.
Pynomonie in der Aus.
Die finanzielle Diagnostik vor uns zum Beispiel ein Brunschitis.
Oder ein Pymonellenbolli im Betracht.
Um meine Verdacht zu bestätigen, würde ich
erst mal die Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Worauf achten Sie da besonders?
Beim körperlichen Untersuchung natürlich die wichtigste Autofektation.
Dann höre ich die Patienten ab.
Und beim Lungen können wir raschen Geräusche abdrehen.
Vielleicht ist Tridow, kann man auch erkennen.
Atemfrequenz vielleicht.
Können wir auch das Herz abhören, ob alles in Ordnung ist.
Was machen Sie weiter an Untersuchung?
Als zweiter können wir eine EKG durchführen, um die Herzkrankheiten aufzuschließen.
Danach brauchen wir natürlich eine Blutuntersuchung.
Im Labor können wir die Enttunungparameter überprüfen.
Und das große Bild müssen wir gucken.
Und der DEMA soll man auch das überprüfen.
Ach so wegen der Lungenembole.
Was untersuchen Sie noch im Labor?
Herzwerte?
Denken Sie mal weg vom Blut.
Denken Sie mal woanders hin.
Also können wir natürlich ein Schlüssel unter dem Durchschluss durchführen.
Unter dem Mikroschulich brauchen wir auch eine Kulturantibiogramme.
Und möglicherweise auch eine Blutkultur.
Dann können wir auch die Patienten in die Wartenschicken...
Was erwarten Sie, was da zu sehen ist?
Eine Verschattung in Lungen- oder Plöreerbos.
Also Pneumoni-Zeichen.
Und als weitere Diagnostik kann man auch ein CT-Untersuchung durchführen.
Und was wäre pulmonologisch noch für eine Untersuchung macht?
Wobei das würde man sicherlich im Augenblick, so wie es der Frau geht, nicht unbedingt machen.
Das wäre noch eine Option.
Aber eine Lungenfunktion würde man akut nicht machen.
Weil es dafür zu schlecht geht.
Ja, denke ich auch.
Es ist hiermit aufgeführt, aber so wie ich die Patienten beschrieben habe,
passt das nicht so gut.
Was wäre Ihre Therapieoption?
Als Therapieoption, wenn unser Verdacht beschätigen, als Pneumoni,
dann können wir direkt die Antibioserapie geben,
als mit Pneumoni-Zeichen oder Pneumoni-Zeichen.
Das kann man auch geben, um Zephalosporin, kann man geben,
und Kinolone, kann man auch geben.
Was würden Sie als erste Maßnahme daran sehen?
Erstmal muss der Patient stationär aufgenommen werden.
Die Patientin, ne?
Natürlich müssen wir die Antikräte kundigen, als Infusion.
Antibioterapie, auch kann man auch, umhaltsügerlich,
sie hat auch Atemnoten, deswegen können wir auch Dauerstoff geben.
Genau.
Und auch mal gucken, den Flüssigkeitshaushalt unter Umständen auffüllen.
Je nachdem, ob die exikiert ist oder nicht.
Dann gucken Sie mal zügig, was aus Ihrer Patientin wird.
Halten Sie mich auf dem laufenden, was am Untersuchungsergebnis rausgekommen ist.
Und dann hoffen wir, dass es der Dame bald wieder besser geht.
Alles klar.
Gut.
Von mir aus ist es nichts dazu zufügen.
Das ist sehr gut.
Ein Kommentar, eine Anmerkung, eine Idee, eine Frage zu der Patientin.
Keine Frage.
Ja? Welche?
Keine Frage, Sie haben erst gesagt.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Bei Behandlung, welche Antibiotika ist erstes?
Sollen wir erst am Oxtrin denken oder noch komplizieren?
Bin ich natürlich raus.
Kann ich nicht sagen, ich habe hier Pinnicillin oder Klaridromizin,
wenn Allergie gegen Pinnicillin bekannt ist.
Also die würden als erste Wahl Pinnicillin geben.
Aber es ist natürlich auch schon älterer Fall.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Bei den Differenzialdiagnosen war ich hier noch.
Da war ein ganzer Katalog aufgeführt.
Einige hast du gesagt, was nicht dabei war, war.
Verdacht auf dem Brunchalkazinom.
Ja.
Und dann.
Ja, wobei, da hat die eigentlich auch keine Symptome für gezeigt.
Das ist ja ganz neu.
Schneumotorax.
Aber das finde ich jetzt ein bisschen exotisch.
So wie die Patientin beschrieben wird.
Aber also war ich hier mit aufgeführt.
Natürlich soll man auch Covid denken.
Ja klar.
Also das haben die tatsächlich,
haben die tatsächlich hier mit aufgeführt,
dass es ja auch schon vor Covid-Zeiten war.
Ja, das ist auch gut.
Also,
heute würde man das sicherlich ungefähr als erstes machen.
Ja.
Gut.
Wie hast du dich gefühlt?
Ja, das ist gut.
Alles gut.
Ich bin ja nicht so in die Übung, was fremd an einem Lesen angeht.
War das ungefähr nach Vollzimmer?
Ja, ja.
Manchmal kommt ich meins in der
Situation, wo ich mich so wirklich, du musst überhaupt keine Sorge
vor dieser Prüfung haben.
Ja, du hast unheimlich viele Anamnesen selber gemacht.
Die waren auch immer alle gut.
Und du hast ja auch noch unendlich viele gehört.
Mein Gott, wie oft warst du dabei?
Ja, also ich glaube, da kann dir wirklich nicht viel passieren.
Und
so ein paar sprachliche Feinheiten, das darf auch mal sein.
Und das ist auch ganz charmant.
Ja, also ich finde, das kann man wirklich durchgehen lassen.
Okay.
Okay, vielen Dank.